Let's pretend again, for a minute, that's Grant's interest is compounded just
one time a year. If you invest that same $10,000 at that same 3% annual rate,
then after four years, he'll have this amount of money, as we saw before. Let's
talk about what this means, this expression here. $10,000 represents the
principle. This initial amount of money he invested and it goes right here.
Point o three here is the interest rate written as a decimal. Three percent
becomes point o three. Then last but not least we have our exponet four. This
represents the number of years that the money has been invested in the account.
Now this worked fine for compounding just one time a year, but it's not going
to work as well for compounding twice a year. If we switch the compounding to
twice a year instead of once a year, then this is the expression we came up
with. So what can we say about comparing these two expressions we've just seen?
I'd like you to tell me that by filling in this sentence. When we switch from
compounding interest once a year to twice a year, what happens to the interest
rate and what happens to the exponent here?